Коронавірус - те саме, що й грип. Від масок більше шкоди, ніж користі. Від локдауну - лише проблеми,
а обмеження вигадали, щоб контролювати людей.
Це найпоширеніші закиди коронавірусних скептиків. Ось кілька прикладів із профілю Deutsche Welle Українською у Фейсбуку:
DW зібрала найважливіше про коронавірус і грип - як їх відрізняти і що небезпечніше.
Чимало симптомів грипу й ковіду збігаються. До власне коронавірусних, німецькі медики зараховують
втрату смаку й нюху на тлі відсутності нежитю. І характерний сухий кашель.
Решта симптомів - як-от висока температура, втома, нежить - можуть проявлятися за обох хвороб.
Під час грипу вже за 3-4 дні настає полегшення. У ковідних хворих навпаки за кілька днів
може різко погіршитися самопочуття.
Втім, за статистикою, більшість позитивних на "ковід" людей переносять хворобу у неважкій формі.
Цікаво ще, що серед пацієнтів із важким перебігом грипу 14 відсотків опиняються на апаратах ШВЛ.
Для коронавірусу цей показник вищий - 22 відсотки.
При цьому грипозним хворим легені вентилюють у середньому лише 4 дні, а ковідним - 10.
І коронавірус, і грип - вірусні захворювання. Обидва передаються повітряно-крапельним шляхом
- головним чином коли інфікований кашляє, чхає, сякається.
На 100 відсотків від обох вірусів може захистити хіба що повна відсутність контактів.
Знизити ризик зараження можна передусім за рахунок дотримання дистанції -
мінімум півтора метра, а також носіння маски.
Стовідсоткового захисту маски не дають, але вірусологи погоджуються, що навіть домашні тканинні маски
допомагають суттєво зменшити дозу отриманого вірусу.
Маски слід регулярно міняти або прати, кімнати провітрювати і не забувати про миття рук і повсякденну гігієну.
Коли говорять про заразність вірусів, згадують індекс репродукції - R.
Він показує, скількох людей може інфікувати носій. Для грипу в розпал сезону цей індекс коливається від 1,2 до двох.
Для коронавірусу, за даними ВООЗ, він становить у середньому по світу 2,5.
На початку пандемії у деяких країнах він сягав навіть п'яти.
У передачі коронавірусу, як свідчать дослідження, велику роль відіграють так звані суперпоширювачі
- люди, які інфікують велику кількість інших. Тому, додають науковці, стаються так звані кластерні спалахи
- масові зараження на вечірках, весіллях, церковних службах.
Теоретично суперпоширювачем може виявитися кожен. Ці люди нерідко самі не мають виражених симптомів.
Грип можуть лікувати противірусними препаратами. Проти нього є ефективні щеплення.
Медики особливо радять їх людям із груп ризику: старшим за 60, тим, хто має сердцево-судинні хвороби, діабет, астму, тощо.
Тим часом щеплення від коронавірусу лише розробляються.
Фахівці виходять з того, що вакцина проти коронавірусу з'явиться не раніше березня наступного року.
І поки дійде до пацієнтів, мине не один місяць, попереджають вірусологи.
Єдина вакцина - російського виробництва - яку почали щеплювати людям у Росії, не отримала міжнародного схвалення.
Спеціальних ліків від коронавірусу також ще немає.
Найбільшу ефективність наразі показав противірусний препарат "Ремдесивір" - розроблений від лихоманки Ебола.
А тим, хто потребує кисневої терапії, можуть давати "Дексаметазон" -
глюко-кортико-стероїд протизапальної дії. Ці препарати, до речі, отримував президент США Дональд Трамп,
який раніше заявляв, що коронавірус - те саме, що й грип.
За даними ВООЗ, летальність сезонного грипу коливається у межах - нуль цілих однієї десятої -
нуль цілих двох десятих відсотка і не сильно відрізняється у більшості країн світу.
Тим часом летальність від коронавірусу суттєво різниться: приміром, в Італії сягає 10 відсотків,
8 у Великобританії, 4 з половиною у Нідерландах, 3 - у Німеччині.
В Україні наразі "ковідна" летальність - 1,9 відсотка.
Науковці, щоправда, зауважують, що порівнювати скільки людей помирають від грипу й коронавірусу - немає сенсу.
Адже методика збору даних за цими хворобами різна.
У будь-якому разі без обмежувальних заходів померлих від "ковіду" було б ще більше, додають науковці.